peu importe ce que je suis imparable et
tout le monde dans cet univers de taille entière est
imparable
[Musique]
J'ai voyagé dans 26 pays mais le
seul pays où je ne me sentais pas en sécurité est
ici en Amérique J'espère que vous vous souviendrez de
Tony comme vous  votez pour les législateurs qui
croient au droit d'une personne de vivre, peu
importe sa couleur de peau ou son code
postal, des enfants comme moi ont fait tout ce qui était
en notre pouvoir et puis certains maintenant c'est votre
tour les adultes nous rendent fiers c'est à la fois triste
que personne à mon école n'y soit allé  avec moi
mais je savais que j'étais seul ils ont dit
pourquoi tu sors sur l'herbe quand
et je leur ai dit que j'allais honorer les
gens qui ont été tués par balle comme mon
cousin Tony
[Musique]
donc à tous les enfants là-bas  Je dirais que
si quelqu'un essaie de vous faire taire avec
ses mots, vous l'avez fait taire avec vos
actions incroyables et même si vous êtes minuscule
comme moi, votre voix ne l'est pas
[Musique]